all right breaking news
an unidentified object heading towards
earth was detected by star labs
stay tuned for updates
[Music]
i don't want him to feel different he is
different
he lifted a tractor with one finger
martha
whoever put him in that ship had no idea
or care for how dangerous a world they
were sending him to
breaking news an unidentified object
heading towards earth was detected by
star labs
look up in the sky
why are you here why are you here
kryptonian
lois and you are i'm clark kent
this planet is protected alien
i thought martians only existed in the
movies
those movies are terrible
are you right miss lane what's the s for
superman
those people are in great danger
let them go
my name is kal-el of krypton and i come
in peace
if they knew about you maybe they'd see
things differently or
maybe the government will lock him up
superman is trying to let the world know
that by showing the good
side of being an alien that might change
people's minds
so for clark it's an acceptance of his
powers and his responsibility for the
world
to share that with everyone this
president knows a good investment when
he sees it
[Music]
what do you do now you've already taken
down the most powerful man in the world
have i
i hope fans see this as a new beginning
but i'm really excited to see not only
the new look but
these sort of new performers that are uh
taking on these voices for the first
time
you read about it tomorrow on the daily
planet i love you bye i
can't say i'm trying to mimic or run
from any of the guys before i think
inevitably just by being me
hopefully it'll be unique are you right
miss lane
as much of a responsibility as it is
it's so also
fun to be able to play a character
everybody knows
i love dipping into these worlds that
are so established and so
fully realized that we get to take it in
new directions
i hope when people see the movie they
feel like we have done
justice to superman that they feel
like we've reintroduced him
in a way that is faithful
to what we know and what we love about
the character
poor goodness in it
he's superman and he's the superman you
love you were right
this was the fun way
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is gonna be my new superman movie
trailer that's right we have a brand new
superman movie just happens to be
animated i know we have dc fandom coming
up this weekend people are hoping for
some kind of henry cavill
man of steel or hopefully new superman
live action news in the dc eu so we'll
break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter eggs and
obviously all the movie trailers that
they're going to be dropping this
weekend too
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what your favorite
dc animated movie is i know a lot of you
are probably gonna say justice league
apocalypse war
that sort of reset the continuity of dc
animated movies so we'll explain how
this movie fits into the new dc animated
universe that they're creating
just starting with the footage first and
i'll explain what's going on because
they have some new voice actors playing
the characters like a new version of
superman new version of lois lane
but this is just meant to hype up lobo
lobo is only one of the villains during
this movie so it sort of chronicles
superman rise it's sort of like superman
year one
then him slowly meeting all the biggest
characters and biggest villains from his
comics like eventually you see him meet
lex luthor what does the s
stand for i know a lot of people were
curious about that because you have the
whole henry cavill man of steel superman
s
stands for hope that zack snyder created
but this just basically says it stands
for superman that's what the s
is for but it is part of the canon that
he doesn't start calling himself
superman until lois lane calls him
superman once he puts on the costume for
the first time
so a lot of the footage in this gives
off a very smallville vibe where he's
being superman doing superman things
learning about his powers like he learns
how to fly he goes to try and stop
lobo before he's actually taken the
superman name
a lot of you saw lobo wearing the green
ring and you're like wait a minute is
lobo wearing a green lantern
ring that's crazy no it's probably just
green kryptonite rock and he uses that
when he's fighting superman
lobo is meant to be a really badass
villain he is super strong he has his
own power set without the need for a lot
of enhancements
because his main ability is just
regenerating himself from a single drop
of his own blood
there was a big joke about that during
young justice season 3 that i'll talk
about in a second
but because lobo is really street smart
so to speak i mean you're talking about
the intergalactic space lanes
he would know how to fight kryptonians
he would know that they're weak against
kryptonite
as you've probably seen the animation
style is vastly different from the other
dc justice league animated movies like
justice league apocalypse war
that's part of the big reboot of the dc
animated universe
although technically the ending of that
movie implied that they're gonna do a
rebirth
storyline they'll be like a justice
league rebirth movie eventually
but as part of the whole reboot they're
just taking opportunities to try new
animation styles try new actors so i
don't know if they're gonna do sequels
to this movie maybe if it's successful
enough
you also probably noticed the animation
style seems very similar to the classic
superman the animated series that bruce
tim and his crew did after batman the
animated series
as the producers talk about the story
gives off a very superman american alien
vibe like what would it be like if
superman actually showed up on a real
earth how would humanity treat him how
would he fit in how would he win them
over
obviously he's superman so he does win
them over through his actions
but a lot of his fight with lobo and
some of the other villains especially
lex luthor are meant to highlight that
struggle within him like how does he
relate to humanity
usually that's through the lowest lane
character she's sort of his proxy for
humanity
that's why their relationship is so
important to superman's story to
humanizing him and making
him feel like an actual real character
because he's so god-tier powerful
you also probably spotted the voice over
actors in this darren chris
is playing superman and alexandra
d'addario is playing lois lane i know a
lot of you are hoping that she'd
actually come into the live-action
movies is zatanna or one of the other
characters there are rumors about them
doing a zatanna movie but i think that
they would do justice league dark first
there's also a live-action justice
league dark hbo series that jj abrams
production company is doing i don't know
if he's personally working on it but bad
robot
is doing it a lot of that stuff a lot of
the upcoming dc projects and the
unannounced
big movies that they're doing they'll
talk about a dc fandom this weekend
there are some secret movie panels
there's the ones we know about and the
trailers like the batman panel with matt
reeves hopefully a teaser for that movie
zack snyder said he's going to drop a
new justice league snyder cut trailer
there's going to be a new wonder woman
1984 trailer
james gunn said he's going to reveal a
bunch about the characters for the new
suicide squad movie that's coming out
next year
but there's also a special secret movie
panel with a couple unannounced projects
so people are just wondering what those
secret dc movies they're working on are
going to be
we know about a couple of them already
like the green lantern corps movie or
the dark side new gods movie that
they've been working on for a while now
but also big heads up they're going to
be screening the superman man of
tomorrow movie for free
at dc fandom there's supposed to be a
special area on their website called the
quote unquote screening room
and they didn't say when that's going to
happen but sometime this weekend they
will be screening the movie for free
as the trailer says it'll be coming out
pretty soon too so you'll be able to buy
a video on demand or stream it
the other brand new animated movie that
we know about but haven't seen any
footage from is actually
batman the long halloween movie that's
supposed to come out sometime next year
i'm really excited to see what they're
gonna do with that
because the matt reeves live action
robert pattinson batman movie is based
on the long halloween
everyone let me know in the comments
what are you most hyped up about this
weekend for dc fandom and actually
big news jensen ackles who played red
hood in the batman under the red hood
movie
is going to be coming to the boys season
3 next year
click here for that teaser and to learn
about the character that he's playing
it's a big funny marvel avengers easter
egg
and click here for my video about the
batman 2021 movie and all the other big
trailers are going to be dropping this
weekend
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
you